should Phil make herself dispute their
own work yeah sure
unless someone else is going to
distribute it for you but look the
number of distributors has shrunk so
much and the number of movies that
studios release has gone from about two
hundred five years ago to about 135 last
year so if you want your movie to have
theatrical distribution you have to
explore all of your options but yeah you
should really explore self distribution
now what I mean by self distribution may
be a little bit different from what you
may think of about self distribution
because I think there's a real value in
having distribution professionals at
your side as you try to distribute your
movie so generally what I counsel
filmmakers to do if they're making a
movie that might have a budget of at
least 500,000 to a million dollars is
build some money into their fund raise
for distribution at the beginning
don't try to raise that money at the end
build it in at the beginning so you can
make the case to your investors who are
gonna say but are you sure the movies
even gonna get seed five thousand movies
a year in America don't even get see
maybe it's ten thousand movies and you
can say yes I can guarantee you this
movie's going to get out there and get
distribution in at least twelve markets
because we've built the money into the
budget and you probably want to build
between depending on the size of the
movie the number of markets that you
want to be in between a hundred thousand
and three hundred thousand dollars into
your budget
so you can sort of see that maybe this
takes your budget from a million to a
million three but it's not like it takes
your budget budget from a million so
five it just adds something you criminal
but it is a great insurance policy for
your investors that the movies actually
going to get out to the marketplace
which means that people can see it
theatrically it's going to get reviews
you're gonna get publicity people have
you on their radio shows and on their
podcasts and you can get it out there a
little bit and then what you can do is
is retain on
tract distribution professionals who
will help you market and book your movie
in theaters and there's a number of
really good ones if any of your
constituents want to get some
recommendations they can come and find
me and I'd be happy to pass that along
and I think there's a real that's a
really good way to do it now of course a
lot of people don't have that budget
they're making movies that are at the
twenty thousand dollar level and then
you really do have to do it yourself and
then that's just the experience of
booking the theaters yourself and go in
there and getting people to do it keep
getting people to show up and that's
that's a lot of work but if you're gonna
make a twenty thousand dollar movie that
is kind of the ticket that you've chosen
to ride so that's that's the game you've
chosen to play
you